- We don't know who leaked the draft
of the Supreme Court opinion
that overturns Roe v. Wade
and Planned Parenthood v. Casey.
Was it a clerk, a justice?
Well, either way, is
someone going to jail?
Well, the Supreme Court
operates in secret.
Famously, they don't even allow cameras
or video recording during oral argument.
But nothing the Supreme
Court does is classified,
and it doesn't appear that
there's any specific law
that makes the leak illegal,
and leaks have happened in
the Supreme Court before.
The Roe decision itself was
leaked before it was public,
as was the decision in Dred Scott.
And there are a bunch of books
from after the fact from insiders
and clerks like Eddie
Lazarus and Jeffrey Toobin.
So Supreme Court leaks happen,
but they are pretty rare.
This one might be the most public
and Justice Roberts' head is
certainly going to explode,
but there may not be
any criminal liability
for someone who did it.
So to paraphrase law
professor Steve Vladeck,
the leak is a story,
but it's not the story.